et avec cette nouvelle vague de chaleur
que nous ressentons tous une question se
pose de manière de plus en plus
pressante quel effort sommes nous prêts
à faire pour limiter nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre pour réduire notre
consommation d'énergie ce sera au coeur
du plan de sobriété énergétique qui a
été annoncé par emmanuel macron qui
devrait concerner les commerces les
logements les collectivités et pourquoi
pas les entreprises du numérique bonjour
jean noël barrot bon jour serena selon
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
sur france info vous êtes le ministre
délégué en charge de la transition
numérique alors il ya quelques jours
olivier ferrand le porte-parole de votre
gouvernement s'était attiré quelques
moqueries en appelant les français à
couper le wifi pour faire des économies
d'énergie j'imagine que vous allez pas
vous limiter à ça vous l'avez rappelé le
président de la république le 14 juillet
a lancé un appel à la mobilisation
générale pour la sobriété avec un
objectif clair baissé de 10% notre
consommation énergétique en réponse à la
crise de la guerre en ukraine et moi
j'ai la conviction que le numérique les
entreprises du numérique et des télécoms
peuvent jouer un rôle clé dans la
transition énergétique et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je les ai convié la
semaine dernière jeudi dernier à bercy
avec agnès pannier-runacher ma collègue
chargé de la transition énergétique pour
les entendre et le premier constat c'est
que l'empreinte carbone la consommation
énergétique du secteur est relativement
modeste mais que pour autant les
entreprises veulent se montrer
exemplaire occasion pris dès jeudi
dernier des engagements pour réduire la
luminosité et baisser la température
dans leurs bureaux et dans leur corps
relativement modeste pour rappeler
quelques chiffres quand même le
numérique consomme 12 % de la
consommation électrique dix les chiffres
officiels 3 % de la consommation
d'énergie finale selon une étude qui est
paru récemment le numérique produits 3,5
pour cent des gaz à effet de serre c'est
plus que le trafic aérien c'est quand
même pas anodin
c'est pas anodin mais là où le numérique
peut jouer un rôle important c'est
lorsque les entreprises que je citais
qui sont venus prendre des premiers
engagements la semaine dernière prendre
de nouveaux engagements septembre elles
s'y sont engagées elles vont ils
travailler cet été et que par ailleurs
elles peuvent offrir un certain nombre
de solutions aux autres acteurs
économiques aux autres organisations que
ce soit les administrations que ce soit
les entreprises et même les particuliers
parce qu'avec
le numérique avec la technologie on peut
trouver des solutions qui vont vous
permettre d'économiser de l'électricité
d'économiser du gaz et c'est ce que nous
allons essayer de proposer lorsque nous
allons les rencontrer puisque je leur ai
donné rendez vous au mois de septembre
ça veut dire que vous les avait conviés
mais que ce n'était pas forcément prévu
qu'il fasse partie
tous et ses géants du secteur du plan de
sobriété énergétique je crois que la
planque et je crois que le plan des
lauréates énergétique tout le monde est
appelé à y participer et je crois que
les entreprises du secteur des télécoms
et du numérique souhaite d'abord se
montrer exemplaires dans la période qui
s'ouvre est par ailleurs montré avoir un
certain nombre de solutions qu'elles
peuvent offrir aux françaises et aux
français et surtout aux entreprises aux
administrations pour réussir ce défi et
réduire très rapidement notre
consommation électrique et notre
consommation de gaz ça peut être quoi
par exemple s'il fallait donner un
exemple concret d'un engagement qui
pourrait être prise dans les prochains
mois sous votre égide par les
entreprises du secteur jean noël barrot
et ça peut être dans le fonctionnement
comme elle comme je le disais tout à
l'heure de leurs opérations quotidiennes
c'est à dire le fonctionnement de leurs
de leurs bureaux de leurs locaux de
commerce elles ont pris des premiers
engagements elles vont essayer d'aller
un peu plus loin elles peuvent aussi
optimiser un peu plus qu'elles ne le
font déjà la consommation électrique je
pense aux entreprises de
télécommunications qui peuvent jouer sur
l'alimentation de leurs réseaux pour
économiser en énergie mais je le disais
aussi l'un des éléments très importants
c'est d'identifier quelles sont les
solutions dont elle dispose qu elles
peuvent mettre à disposition d'autres
secteurs d'autres acteurs pour que même
puisse très rapidement franchir la
marche et là je donne quelques exemples
mais avec vous savez des capteurs
installés dans une dans une entreprise
ou dans une usine vous pouvez assez
rapidement optimiser la consommation
électrique en réduisant et bien la
lumière quand vous n'en avez pas besoin
et c'est ça c'est des solutions qui sont
rendues possibles par la technologie et
c'est ce que nous voulons essayer de
déployer rapidement pour atteindre les
objectifs fixés par le président la
république est ce que ça va être
compatible avec vos autres objectifs les
autres missions qui sont sur votre
feuille de route jean-noël barrot
demandé aux grandes entreprises de faire
des efforts d'être plus sobre et en même
temps de faire de la france une grande
nation du numérique on peut trouver un
équilibre entre entre les deux objectifs
oui je crois que le grand objectif c'est
que collectivement nous puissions
démocratiser nommé d'abord en soutenant
nos entreprises qui sont nos entreprises
du numérique qui sont devenus des
champions ces cinq dernières années et
que nous devons amener à devenir des
leaders pour maîtriser les technologies
de demain et assurer notre souveraineté
ensuite en mettant fin à la loi du plus
fort dans l'espace numérique qui doit
cesser d'être une zone de non-droit faut
réguler davantage il faut réguler
davantage et l'europe sous présidence
française ces six derniers mois a fait
des pas de géant dans cette direction et
puis enfin c'est rendre universel
l'accès au numérique le numérique doit
bénéficier à tous et aujourd'hui dans
votre pays des millions de français des
centaines de milliers de commerçants et
d'artisans qui sont éloignés du
numérique et nous devons les accompagner
1 1 si je puis dire une à une pour tenir
notre rang de grandes nations du
numérique ça veut dire que c'est
l'europe qui fait tousser pas la france
ah non sur certaines dimensions c'est la
france quand on parle d'inclusion quand
on parle d'amener les 13 millions de
français qui se sentent éloignés du
numérique à pouvoir se saisir de ces
usages bien c'est un accompagnement
humain parce que la numérisation passe
toujours par le rapport humain nous
avons l'année dernière lancer un plan de
conseillers numérique quatre mille
conseillers numérique partout sur le
territoire qui accompagnent les
françaises et français éloigné du
numérique nous venons de pérenniser ces
4000 postes et nous allons aller plus
loin c'est un engagement du président de
la république et je suis très attaché il
est chiffré cet engagement oui en tout
cas c'est une enveloppe budgétaire de 44
millions d'euros qui a été sécurisé la
première ministre a annoncé la semaine
dernière ça va nous permettre de
sécuriser de pérenniser ces postes pour
pouvoir envisager d'aller plus loin -
numérique plus sobre plus accessible
aussi si je vous crois en tout cas c'est
la feuille de route que vous nous
présentez ce matin remercie beaucoup
jean noël barrot d'être venu nous voir
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
bonne journée à vous merci à vous